u.s president joe biden has announced
billions of dollars of funding to help
the country deal with the impact of
climate change which he calls a clear
and present danger
he says the money will help communities
protect their infrastructure from
extreme weather
many rice farmers in the north of italy
are on the brink of financial ruin as
the region suffers from the worst
drought in 70 years the lack of water
has destroyed much of the harvest in a
moment we will look at the link between
global heating and drought but first
this report from dw's max sander
a marina full of stranded boats
fields of drooping sunflowers and
everywhere fountains with no running
water
scorching temperatures of up to 40
degrees have been plaguing northern
italy for weeks now and threatening some
people's very existence
like the region's rice farmers
these plants are completely dead they
won't produce anything there will be no
crop here
15 tons of harvest lost in this plot
alone the farmer simply couldn't provide
enough water
stefano grepi is the head of the
coloretti pavia association which
represents farmers in the region
italy's so-called golden rice triangle
makes up half of europe's entire rice
production
the industry which is highly dependent
on water is now facing a financial and
environmental catastrophe
to our knowledge nothing like this has
ever happened in the last 70 years
according to the data available a
drought like this has never occurred
never
mine
northern italy depends on the po river
its 650 kilometers span the country from
west to east it is a source of life for
all around it but water levels have been
dropping continuously over the last few
years
so this summer large parts of italy's
longest river essentially are looking
like this i'm walking on what used to be
the poe's riverbed and if you have a
close look here you can see
the bottom is actually
covered in what is seashells
right and this is dramatic for a number
of reasons um the people here
in the region depend on this water for
drinking water purposes to create energy
and also for agriculture
areas are now competing for the
remaining water a state of emergency has
been declared in many regions experts
say the situation is likely to occur
again but there are certain precautions
that can be taken to alleviate future
drought
there is focus on increasing the water
storage capacities
meaning
storing water in winter in big or small
reservoirs
that of course depends on rainfall in
winter which has been scarce this year
as well
reducing leaks is another big topic in
italy both for drinking water and
agricultural purposes
the system efficiency is currently
around 50 per cent
farmers like stefano grippy also know
they will have to change this season
they have already lost 30 percent of
their harvest
we hope we'll get back to a climate
which allows for rice production
otherwise we'll have to switch to other
crops and adapt to a different type of
water management
there's just not enough water for
everyone
for now all they can do is keep the
pumps running and hope for falling
temperatures
and above all for rain
and michael singer is deputy director of
the water research institute at cardiff
university in wales he explained why
climate change is causing water
shortages like those we just saw in that
report
tell us a little bit more about this
link between climate change and water
scarcity why is it leading to shortages
such as the ones that we just saw in
that report
yeah the main thing to remember is that
under a warming atmosphere more water is
drawn from the land surface back into
the atmosphere and that is leading to a
concentration of climatic extremes such
as drought and floods and they don't
always happen in the same place and they
shift around the globe
such as what we're seeing right now in
italy um
the when we have less rain we have less
soil moisture we have less runoff and
less stream flow in in river channels
and also lower groundwater tables and
this can lead to widespread effects
across the landscape
and how will the lack of rainfall impact
the global food supply do you think
well it's really important to understand
that
most of the world is not um irrigating
crops only 20 percent of global
agriculture is irrigated so there are
there are
large swaths of the world that are under
subsistence agriculture and struggling
under
rain-fed agriculture that um where rains
are failing um a recent example of this
is in the horn of africa where there are
is four failed rainy seasons in a row
leading to widespread famine and food
insecurity but we see this within the
developed world as well
clearly in italy we see
a failed
rainy season in the winter and low
snowpack that has ultimately led to
a very hot dry summer and then you see
the po drying up and the impacts on
irrigation and agriculture there so
there will be periods like this across
the globe that
where agriculture really suffers so
given that agriculture as you've
highlighted there is the major user of
water in most countries do you
anticipate that we're going to see
increasing competition for water between
countries
um absolutely there there are already um
major conflicts and discussions um about
water in places like ethiopia sudan and
egypt there are
conflicts between the us and mexico and
other places around the world as well um
there is it's often said that we will
have future water wars but i hope that
we can avoid this dystopian future by
potentially discussing right now how we
share this sensitive
resource across the globe
what do you hope might materialize in
such discussions what can the world do
to safeguard its water supply
so the main thing is that there are many
places in the world that have been
suffering from this sort of circumstance
already places like australia california
and the southwestern u.s have gone
through decades already of drought
conditions and they've had to make lots
of hard choices um imposing restrictions
on water use and creating compacts
between agricultural municipal
and societal interests to
achieve a better outcome of sharing this
precious resource
there are many solutions that have that
could be
implemented but it requires a deep
conversation amongst interested parties
thank you so much michael singer deputy
director of the water research institute
cardiff university in wales we
appreciate your time
thank you
you